What's up everybody!
Welcome to another episode of Challenge Pongfinity.
This is the series where YOU challenge US
with your craziest ideas related to table
tennis.
If your comment gets picked
we will feature it in our next video
and give you a shout out.
So make sure you leave your comments and ideas
in the comment-section below!
Triple K wants me to stick a bat to my head
and play with it.
Global Threat wants us to make an around the
net shot with a construction hammer.
Let's do this.
Orel Mizrahi wants us to make a shot between
two card houses.
Nsubetathenu wants me to do 50 around the
net shots.
FInally I get a proper challenge!
Otto: There it was hopefully, 50 in a row.
Emil: Empty box also, no more balls left!
Thanks for watching guys!
If you are new to the channel subscribe here.
And watch the previous episodes here!
Until next time!